finally we imagine
I'm going to run as fast as possible
I can
to hide
the end of the street el mate aldo
gutierrez
that is, when they started firing fell
he was immediately shot in the
head
since then a one has been undertaken
great fight
d
the cessation is called
Saul Bruno García
also without being my best friend because
well
the ones sleeping next to me
I like to be told juli because
because he has a lot of strength
he got up two boys like that together
and exercise
it was very
the charismatic the company very good wave
Paradoxes of being a mother of mothers and a
little less heavy with me I had a
shit of plans with that partner
Sometimes I put some noise in the street
Today I get up thinking that friend
at any time you can get in my
son cristian rodríguez de lumbre
is missing
and that he does not feel alone that his parents
mom your brothers are looking for
Ferrero is one of the poorest countries
from Mexico
Perez to families with their children
barefoot with their children without clothes
there are people who do not have
day to day to go eating
this school is the hope of many
families is the hope of many
kids who want to keep going
they want to get ahead
And then here, more than anything, now
remove the blindfold could
say you live the reality
the rural normals were created from
of the revolution and what was the end of
that revolution earth freedom and
education for children and peasants
the state federal government
sound with a municipal for
disappear the rural normals because
they no longer want education
as
we unfortunately have systems
and where corrupt police officers operate with
corruption with a drug trafficking
we are not criminals we
we are students that we look for a better
future
Y
how the government has been playing with
the feelings of parents and
ayotzinapa students saying that then
in a moment our people are dead
companions
at another time say they are alive
I do not trust them because the pgr
we as parents do not not
We have confidence the true
information with arguments with everything be
that is true
people know projects because if they do not
manifests today as the one that goes to
continue to watch 44-45 they gave to follow more
a model of revolution could emerge
the revolution of conscience
it was about two and a half years three years
towards here, it started to be noticed
strongly violence